today's draft without further ado this
year's biggest
disappointments we can go any direction
we want just like we can in any draft
that we do we'll go peter sims then me
peter you get the first pick
my biggest disappointment is cam newton
um
in 2015 cam newton had three
games in which he threw five touchdown
passes
in 2020
cam newton has played 12 games for the
patriots he's thrown five touchdown
passes
and look i know he's coming off injury i
know it's a new system i know blah blah
blah blah blah blah
cam newton is the most disappointing
single aspect of football this year
that that's harsh i don't know if i'm
totally gonna say that but you're i mean
they were on my list i mean why tell me
why well five touchdown passes for cam
newton i i understand games you're right
i mean listen he also had that you know
the covet 19 thing too that i think's
got to be you know talked about as part
of that you know no off season hey it's
certainly it's it's up there i just
don't know if i'm going to say it's the
most disappointing thing for a team that
you know was in the playoff conversation
just a week ago but i understand you i
was certainly expecting more there and
like i said i that probably would have
came up in my draft too so i'm not
disagreeing with you there definitely
not um
you know what i think the most
disappointing thing of the season for me
joe burrow getting hurt
i think that's the the number one whammy
to me more than anything i think about i
just go damn
superstar like everything he brings to
the table for a bengals french franchise
that we just we know needs a little
jolt and joe in this life all right and
jolt and joe had me
actually intrigued to watch the bangles
on a weekly basis and the way he handles
himself in press conference and just how
damn good of a player he is and i think
it hurts me because it might go into
next year too and that's where i look at
that and i'm very disappointed
yeah more than just a normal acl tear
and it could put in jeopardy as
availability for 2021 for me it's carson
wentz without question we've yet to see
a quarterback who was drafted so high
played well enough to be in the mvp
conversation early in his career get a
huge second contract and then have it
all fall apart just a year after they
were five and seven and they had nothing
around carson once and he led them to
the playoffs it's confounding it's
inexplicable and it's disappointing and
it is for me the biggest disappointment
of the year and the question now becomes
where does carson wentz and where do the
eagles go from here in 2021 one of the
big stories of the offseason all right
on to round two
uh
i will pick the houston texans in their
entirety yeah um
you know from bill o'brien going 0-4 and
getting whacked
to uh you know the entire controversy
over who runs this team
uh you know cal mcnair has taken over
for his dad and had a very very
lax hand
uh you know the jack easter b
controversy it's just it's a mess it's
mayhem and where it could impact the
future even though in my opinion
if i were eric b enemy and i had my
choice of four jobs this offseason i
would pick the houston texans because
they got the one thing that everybody
strives to get and that's the
quarterback we'll figure everything else
out but for right now the most
disappointing uh single team
in my opinion this year is the houston
texans yeah i i hear you there peter um
i'm going to see your texans football
team and raise you the team just north
of them the dallas cowboys are you sure
they're as dysfunctional as my dallas
cowboys are
i think there's been more organizational
issues to your point you know with the
the houston texans but man the dallas
cowboys i mean america's team
america's disaster this year what i mean
from everything i mean first off dak
prescott and that whole debacle the the
contract breaks his you know breaks his
ankle now that so that was disappointing
mike mccarthy supposed to you know
rejuvenate the cowboys football team
that hasn't done anything i mean hiring
the wrong defensive coordinator for the
players you have on the football field
let alone he gets tabasco in his eye
during a press conference this year i
mean it's just been a disaster there so
uh that to me has been one of the most
disappointing things of the 2020 season
you know the next one for me and and i'm
gonna go ahead and put both guys down
because i can't pick one or the other
tom brady and antonio brown you know
brady wanted antonio brown so badly he
finally got him when you look at the
numbers antonio brown really hasn't done
much and coming out of the bye week what
fascinated me is his playing time
plummeted that is the result of a
strategic and conscious decision made by
the coaching staff because they had time
to sit down and decide what they were
going to do and what they did coming out
of the pie is they used antonio brown a
lot less than they had so that
connection together has been a
disappointment there are aspects of tom
brady's game that have been
disappointing but this idea that there
was going to be this great reunion and
they were going to reach new heights he
still doesn't have a touchdown through
five games with the tampa bay buccaneers
all right we got to rock it through
round three peter what do you got
you know i was going to pick the new
york jets because they're owen 13
and they provide comic relief almost
every week
but i think the other thing i would have
to do is i'd have to pick the atlanta
falcons and i'd like to identify a
single person but i think
this is a collective achievement award
you know from the whacking of thomas
dimitrov and dan quinn at the beginning
of the year raheem morris has given them
some life
but it's absurd for the atlanta falcons
to be four and nine agreed that was
going to be my next pick uh peter so i'm
with you there i was almost gonna invent
one on the fly i know well i was gonna
almost and put them in the jets together
right because they had that end of the
year last year we were all like whoa
watch out for these teams you know next
year and it's been crapola so yes but
i'll go with this i got one more the
49ers their bad luck their health
whatever the hell you want to call it i
mean that's a disappointment a team that
was in the super bowl very young and
talented not that i expected but just
it's just a shame that we didn't ever
get to see them close to a hundred
percent to see if they could defend
their nfc title and make a run and do
something special it's been a disaster
whether it's been injuries or coven 19
for them all year so the 49ers bad luck
is certainly a disappointment for me
i'll stay in california slide down to la
and say the chargers coaching the entire
coaching staff and i'm sure some guys
have done well whoever has gotten
through to justin herbert the rookie
quarterback has done great but all in
all it's a total failure of the coaching
staff too many bad decisions special
teams gasps it seems like every week
yeah someone on the coaching staff finds
a way to screw things up and they're
going to get everybody fired because
they've got a franchise quarterback that
makes their job incredibly attractive in
2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports